this program is brought to you by Emory
University
travel well was started in 1988 because
we saw a need to see patients prior to
their travel to give them information
about health overseas particularly when
they go to the developing world and in
order to see people either returning
from travel who are ill or new
immigrants and refugees who have begun
to settle in Georgia we see several
thousand people who are traveling from
the Atlanta area either for leisure for
business travel you see a lot of
students a lot of Emory and other
professors in town as well as people who
have immigrated to Atlanta and are going
home to visit friends and relatives so
we see lots of different types of people
well the first thing we do is talk to
them about immunizations we make sure
they're up to date with the routine
immunizations that they should just have
living here or traveling anywhere then
we go through the special immunizations
they may be that may be recommended or
required for travel then we go through
things such as what we call vector-borne
diseases or those diseases transmitted
by insects such as mosquitoes we talk
about safe food and water and a lot of
other issues that come up in for people
who were traveling I think most people
still think when they're going to more
exotic places that it's like going
across country or to France or England
but things can be very very different
elsewhere and it's important that people
have a feel for the kind of environment
they're going into culturally as well as
health wise one of the most common thing
is that travelers get after and during
the time they're in the developing world
as travelers diarrhea we see that quite
frequently and that's probably the most
common illness that we see respiratory
infections are very common then we
actually see diseases like malaria and
dengue fever not uncommonly i would say
areas of expertise are all of travel
medicine any of
kinds of ailments that people acquire
when they travel those that are acquired
prior to immigration for example
tropical diseases and illnesses that are
acquired during crossing borders for
example when there are outbreaks in the
world such as int'l enza h1n1 that we
had SARS or exotic diseases for example
when we had the anthrax problems
bioterrorism
you
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University